we have our science critic and he also
analyzed uh general relativity and so
it's on topic today so let's see what he
had to say about general relativity okay
in space time specifically here goes
listen carefully
the questions and issues to be addressed
in this rebuttal include does gps prove
that general relativity is correct
does space-time explain gravity
does space-time have anything at all to
do with physics
well it's not so much that we wouldn't
have developed gps if general relativity
was incorrect it's more that gps has to
account for general relativity because
otherwise it won't work and the
difference between these two statements
is that in the letter if general
relativity were false we could still
develop gps it just wouldn't have to
account for general relativity i know
that you do not believe in space time
but
the curvature of space time is the
mechanism that causes gravity to occur
or at least that is the best idea that
we currently have
the best idea the mathematicians have
that space time and so the question one
question with gps is the gps prove that
time is a physical object that time can
be warped that time serves as the wall
that prevents the earth from flying out
of the solar system or the moon for that
matter
uh and so that's the first question you
should ask is that a valid physical
interpretation does that make any sense
to you and if they say well you're not
supposed to take the analogy so
literally and we don't care about
physical interpretations we just care
about the math well then why are you
asking a question about mechanisms to a
mathematician first of all and second
why have they
ventured into
what they call philosophy explaining the
mechanism why have they even attempted
that why don't they stay in math and say
look these are the equations and they
can stay there with their description no
problem it's when they cross the line
into physics and say look our equations
we interpret them as this yeah but your
interpretation is ridiculous it's not
even
worthy of consideration we have to lock
you up in a mental asylum if you come up
with that interpretation yeah well
you're not supposed to take it literally
well why did you why did you attempt to
do it in the first place if if your
physical interpretation is garbage and
you're going to reject it at the end of
your tale at the end of your
dissertation
why did you even attempt it why did you
even try why are you trying to give a
physical interpretation to begin with
well i'll tell you why because otherwise
mathematics you know mathematical
physics is worthless it's irrelevant if
they cannot give you a physical
interpretation so they give you a
description
then they give you their physical
interpretation their opinions which are
all ridiculous nonsense
and then they say forget about our
physical interpretations we know because
we do the equations every day and
equations tell us so they have is a
measurement they have a description they
don't have an explanation and this
fellow believes
like so many people out there you know
they're they're fooled into believing
that
general relativity has an explanation
for gravity
a physical interpretation that you know
that warp space what time is what
prevents the earth from flying out of
the solar system they really believe
that they believe that space and time
are physical objects and again that's
the question does gps prove that time is
a physical object and if it doesn't then
gps is technology and has nothing to do
with science
it has nothing to do with science
science we have to explain okay we have
to explain why the gps little thingy
there rolls around the earth where does
it fly out of the solar system
what keeps gps you know the uh the probe
with the um uh gyroscopes what keeps it
rolling around the earth why does it
just keep rolling out is it going around
another space-time depression
its own
dragging space time around itself as
they say so here here's the problem with
what this all says you know again we
have time which is warped and this valve
believes that it's these seconds that
serve as walls to the earth
we have time bent time work time curved
time okay and that's what prevents the
earth from flying out of the solar
system that's the physical
interpretation and then they tell you
well by the way don't take it literally
then what have we learned if we're not
supposed to take this literally
that time is a concept that prevents the
earth a physical object from flying out
of the solar system
jesus christ
okay and uh so what's the problem the
problem is that time is not even a
dimension okay
time is a number line time time does not
have direction time only has magnitude
and time doesn't go perpendicular to
anything because it doesn't have
direction on the other hand length width
and height in the case of dimensions
true dimensions
coordinates
longitude latitude altitude and vectors
like
you know depth breath and elevation all
these have perpendicularity and they
have direction what they lack all of
these is magnitude and number lines have
the opposite have magnitude no direction
no perpendicularity that's why the
you know space time four
four-dimensional space-time is really
for number line not for dimensional okay
dementia is what mathematicians have
because they never define their terms so
they come up with nonsense as far as a
physical interpretation for what's
happening out there